[Musique]
on
une
[Musique]
je m'appelle ieom foucault je suis le
chef du restaurant perty qu'avant
d'homme je le tiens avec ma femme qui
fuit depuis maintenant six ans donc ma
première rencontre avec le métier de
cuisinier c'était dans le petit village
à deux kilomètres à côté de là où j'ai
grandi
c'était un ct et c'est encore un tout
petit restaurant tenu par une seule
personne et je me souviens encore au
mois de décembre
la générosité que ce monsieur pouvait
avoir avec des des repas ouvriers
il courait partout mais il était il
était incroyablement généreux et samaa
ça m'a énormément marqué
donc la recette que l'on va faire
aujourd'hui ce sont des chirac est cuit
à l'italienne avec des oignons et uv et
un sabayon au beurre noisette égard
homme de loi donc on va commencer à
faire prendre le blogueur pour l'amener
jusqu'à cuisson de noisettes donc les
oeufs on met quatre heures les quatre
jeunes 9
donc on va mettre un oignon hommes et
quelques branches de sarriette on va les
enfermer dans le papier d'alu et donc
trente minutes au four l'autre
on va faire chauffer du vinaigre donc
deux fois qu'on va faire infuser avec
quelques branches de rollin on jette les
champignons dedans
ensuite il nous reste plus qu à
assaisonner avec le garam c'est une
fermentation de scène et de poissons
[Applaudissements]
donc il nous reste plus qu à verser ce
sabayon donc l'aromatiser dans un siphon
après une demi-heure au four on obtient
donc un un oignon taille et correctement
et et doux
on a posé les champignons
donc là on rajoute quelques feuilles de
cardamines et donc pour pour finir on va
y mettre le sabayon que nous avons fait
tout à l'heure à base de garonne et
bernoise est ces déchets taquet me crie
à l'italienne avec des oignons
assaisonner avec un tout petit peu de
reine des prés et un sabayon en garante
de loire
[Musique]